[Music]  dear mr. gore three days ago my son  Bailey was taken by wolves no one in the  village will hunt them my husband will  come home from the war soon I must have  something to show him  so you come to kill it - kill the one  that took him I came to help if I can  to explain this if I can it's not the  first time people died out there  hillside this is heart with pieces of  bodies that's what you get when you talk  to the villagers people are dying it's  real enough leavis does it das you're  the one font my boy yes dear a student  knows that I have no questions for  ever seen anything like this before  behavioral turn the savaging no I'm not  talking about animals here mister  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]